federal judge denied preliminary
approval of a 765 million dollar
settlement on NFL concussion claims
we've all seen the videos we're just
getting more and more this guy's can't
remember things Brett Favre etc etc
let's look at some of the details a
younger retiree with Lou Gehrig's
disease would get 5 million under the
deal those with serious dementia cases
would get 3 million an eight-year-old
with early dementia would get 25,000
that seems like nothing retirees without
symptoms would get baseline screening
and follow-up care if needed the
proposed settlement by the way which was
negotiated over seven several months is
designed to last at least 65 years so
again these videos are out I beds the
playoffs right now i'm watching this it
seems like the hits are getting worse
and worse but maybe it's just because
we're getting sensitized to it now
because everyone's talking about it is
this crazy that even a 765
million-dollar deal was not enough in
this judges eyes to do this i mean i
think that the problems are real you
know a lot of these players are playing
through injuries which is part of the
problem you know maybe they get
diagnosis from doctors you know
concussions and whatnot and they and
they continue to play but I'm really
concerned I mean I think it is a growing
problem in like you alluded to I think
that the injuries are getting worse a
friend a really good friend of mine just
did a documentary about traumatic brain
injury and it's an exploration of how
the extreme sports you know like it's
getting so increasingly competitive and
like people are just pushing really
their human bodies to the limits and it
just becoming more and more dangerous
you know there was a two weeks ago there
was like a UFC fight and I don't follow
UFC at all but one of the like I guess
you know best fighters in the world or
something completely shattered his uh
you know all the bones basically in his
lower leg and I just thought that it's
like I mean how is this entertainment
you know like seeing people get so badly
hurt right so we'll get we'll get to
that part because I think that is a key
part but what do you think of the
settlement in general the judge's
decision on the settlement does that you
show you how bad this really it's the
judge's decision is awesome it's
hilarious haha [ __ ] the NFL like this is
like I love football I'd watch it every
week I'm part of the problem
but at the same time is a nine billion
dollar industry the seven or 65 million
dollars is not like for 65 years the
number of athletes that the reason the
judge just decided this was because that
the amount settled on would not actually
cover the things that they're covering
right that they want to cover because
there are so many injuries it's so
prevalent there's so many brain injuries
that's so prevalent that it's just it's
not going to be enough money practically
did you know that Lou Gehrig's disease
was even connected to this I did not
realize that and that's I think what's I
mean when you [ __ ] with people's brains
a lot like that's bad things happen who
knew yeah and it's not and the problem
is i mean NFL is trying to make the game
safer you know targeting hits hits to
the head low to show you know that there
was percy harvin got crushed in that
saints game and so he wasn't you know
when that happens you have to go out
immediately and get a concussion
screening but then he came back after 10
minutes you're supposed to be 15 you
know it's like it's at all 15 minutes
makes it didn't have a concussion you
maybe want to sit or was it every minute
and that's it's you know and yes they're
getting better when you are diagnosed
with a concussion you have to sit out a
game you know like so it's a thing then
about doing what they can to improve but
i think the big thing is the NFL will
have to change in a fundamental way and
i think we're starting to see that but i
think it will continue i think the game
we watch in 10 years or 10 years maybe
it gave me much in 20 years if we're
what like if it's still a thing will
look very different yeah and i think
this settlement the thing that bothers
me out the Selma is everybody kind of
agrees that it's not enough and the
lawyers who were on the player cider
based like yeah but if we go to court
it's really hard to put it like even
though we all know this is what's
causing it's really hard to prove that
this is why all these guys have it yeah
so you hit on a bunch of stuff that I
want to get on there so first up do you
think that some of this may be will be
corrected by science because with stem
cell research and all that kind of stuff
there is a chance that for all of the
the horrible things that are happening
to these guys with dementia and all that
that maybe science will catch up and
sort of mitigate some of the health
issues yeah I mean I think that science
is working in parallel to find you know
solutions for you know these horrible
diseases I mean I Alzheimer's is set
right now to be the
world's next great epidemic I mean the
numbers of people affected are going to
triple by 2050 but i think that like
traumatic brain injury is injury you
know and it's true that like you know
they have pointed TBI traumatic brain
injury to an increased incidence of
things like Lou Gehrig's disease which
is like a terrible disease um and so I
just think that it's I think it's messed
up I mean I don't watch any sports so
I'm like an objective party i think i
think it's just horrible to see more of
a brain guy than a sports guy yeah pro
brain uh what would it take then for a
sports guy like yourself what would it
take for you to actually stop watching
cuz these discussions ESPN's even been
doing a little bit about this is there
some magic number that actually would
turn people away like when if Brett
Favre in two years from now you know
knock on wood but if he really had you
know someone actually I think it's
junior seau I thought was gonna be the
big chain cuz like he was not you know
he's a young guy he was something that
we all remember yeah from not that long
ago as an all-pro for years and he
tragically killed himself because he was
dealing with these things like that it's
and yet no nobody cared I think two
things one ESPN is doing a better job it
is also in a very strange position where
they are the huge financial partner with
the NFL so the top 10 plays in five of
them are crushing hits and then they do
a story and then they pull out of
stories to you know they pulled out of
the frontline documentary about about
this after you know endorse NP we don't
know for sure but it seems and and the
word was because of pressure from the
NFL not to do it because they're which
compromises them as a journalistic
enterprise and they're the journalists
to get to prize in sports so that's a
problem is that the people that are
supposed to be watching this or at least
one of the major players supposed to be
watching this is in bed with the person
they're watching which is a natural
issue i think the the turning point the
thing that will change and i think it's
not impossible is that somebody dies on
the field that would be the like which
is sad that you have to say like
somebody's got to die on the field but
like that's gonna be the thing that like
if that happens and it is certainly
within the realm of possibility which
already is like terrifying
I think that will be the thing that that
would change would get people to really
like the general public to get of it do
you think part of this has to do with
that the amount of money the players
make even though NFL contracts are not
guaranteed but there are most of them
are making millions and millions of
dollars that partly I think people maybe
view this as well it's the risk you take
to make men so there's a a weird lack of
sympathy just because of the salary
they're bringing it does that jive with
you you think that makes sense um I
think that that is what leads some of
them to push through their injuries you
know and play when they shouldn't be
playing yeah I mean money there's no
incentive quite like money right yeah
it's tough because I actually think the
NFL I think that's actually the biggest
problem or it may be the biggest problem
is that the NFL potential career
earnings for the average NFL player are
much lower than the other sports because
one they're fifty five players on our
team is supposed to 25 and baseball or
12 on that in basketball two contracts
aren't guaranteed so an injury means you
stop getting paid potentially and
certainly don't get another contract
necessarily and we focus on people like
Adrian Peterson and and you know Tom
Brady and they're making tons and
millions of but the potential earning
for a guy who's on the offensive line
who's a backup who's gonna make five
hundred thousand dollars a year for five
years but then never make that money
ever again and ask doesn't have maybe
skills that are applicable to the fair
world and gets hit with traumatic brain
injury on top of that can't afford the
medical bills a pension plan isn't great
like you start to you know you start to
see that these aren't necessarily super
rich guys some super rich guys are
dealing with this right there are also
people that ten years out like they need
like yeah maybe they live in a nice
house but like they need to work in a
car dealership right not to be always me
for guys that are making hundred
thousand dollars but a lot of them
haven't dealt with that kind of I
venture to say 99% of them haven't dealt
with that kind of money beforehand they
get financial advisors involved that
screw up all kinds of things and all
these guys end up broke i mean there's a
zillion stories out of that yeah yeah
yeahs fasten and it's such a quick
turnaround too i mean but you look at it
and you one they're paying tens my
agents to they're paying tons of money
to their entourage because they're young
and stupid and by the time they get
smart a lot of them are out of the
league and it's too late and you that
you see constantly that you know ESPN
this is there good journalistic source
in some ways did that great documentary
called broke about how these got how it
happens and it just it's a mixed mixture
of being dumb a mixture of their targets
and they're not necessary like yeah
there are really smart football players
but stereotypes exist for a reason like
these guys aren't brain surgeons and
their targets for smart people who want
to take advantage of them yeah when you
throw in the fact that now they're 50
like the average age the lifespan of an
NFL player is like average age like 65
or something it's like ridiculously low
or maybe even younger than that I've
even seen numbers in the high 50s but
the fact that we all this is the
gladiators like we're watching people
kill themselves for our entertainment
and that is a problem and it's getting
safer yeah and that they're trying to
make it safer so you feel a little
better about it but then hit like the
one Percy Harvin took last weekend makes
you remember like oh yeah this is still
really bad yeah he watches it because
it's safe right right and you know it
really reminds me of hockey which isn't
doing particularly well in America and
if they took the fighting out of that
literally nobody would watch so it's a
layered problem